mais l'om s annonce donc ce soir la
reprise des essais cliniques sur l'idh
roxy chloroquine après les avoir
interrompues suite on le disait à
l'étude du land 7 en france la molécule
a elle été interdite également le 27 mai
aujourd'hui olivier véran demande des
comptes à la revue alors cette
interdiction est elle fondée sur des
faits objectifs le ministre de la santé
est il allé trop vite peut-on parler de
choix politique fait l'objet de notre
face à face ce soir et pour en débattre
nous sommes avec gilbert collard député
européen sur la liste du rassemblement
national bonsoir gilbert collard merci
d'être avec nous ses côtés ou plutôt
face à face à laurent alexandre ancien
chirurgien essayiste bonsoir à vous
aussi laurent alexandre merci d'être là
alors allons droit au but messieurs en
interdisant l'utilisation de cette
molécule en france la semaine dernière
ce que olivier verrons a fait une faute
gilbert collard selon vos jeux
je crois qu'il a lui-même admis sans le
vouloir qu'il avait fait une fois depuis
ce qu'il a déclaré ce n'est pas parce
qu'une étude est contesté qu'elle est
contestable
pourquoi donc alors puisqu'il est
l'auteur de sept de 7 de cet aphorisme
avoir immédiatement interdit les
toxiques lockheed
c'est incompréhensible et ça pose quand
même plein de questions d'autant plus
que comme on l'a dit depuis le début de
votre émission
ce médicament était en vente libre
depuis 70 ans et a été administré plus
d'un milliard d'individus et que jamais
on n'a eu de retour négatif donc on se
pose vraiment la question pourquoi sur
la base d'une étude de deux ans est
aujourd'hui critiquée par zeus est lui
même en a pris la décision immédiate
brutale d'interrompre la possibilité
d'avoir recours à ce médicament prison
en même temps quand même et ça c'est pas
négligeable à mes yeux
le médecin le généraliste du droit de
prescrire ce qui lui paraît bon de
prescrire moi je pourrais médecine libre
je ne suis pas pour une médecine
technocratique et je pense que monsieur
vers a commis une erreur d'appréciation
grave qu'il doit de grèce je le pense
alors à quel regretter puisque l'om s
annonce la reprise des essais cliniques
ce qui est quand même très significatif
alors en laissant vous ne faites pas
partie des grands défenseurs de cette
molécule vous avait alerté voilà sur ses
dangers en tout cas nous invite à être
prudent plusieurs fois sur cette antenne
aujourd'hui quel est votre sentiment
avec ce cafouillage
on voit bien qu'il n'ya pas de consensus
entre les médecins entre les chercheurs
entre les pays
si c'était une molécule extraordinaire
qui guérit les malades
il n'y aurait pas de débat s'il ya débat
c'est parce que l'efficacité de la
molécule est très faible ou nulle et
qu'elle a possiblement des effets
secondaires on y aurait pas débat il n'y
a pas des pays sadique qui veulent tuer
leurs citoyens il ya des pays qui ont
interdit la molécule dans cette
indication
c'est parce qu'on a des inquiétudes
parce que les besoins scolaires est vrai
ces molécules sont des molécules
ancienne mais monsieur collard il ne
faut pas oublier que les effets
secondaires d'un médicament varie d'une
maladie à l'autre si vous et moi on
prend de l'aspirine
il va rien se passer mais si on a une
hémophilie on va faire une hémorragie
grave et on va mourir donc les effets
secondaires des médicaments non mais je
pensais que le médecin vous laissez moi
parler de l'ailé comme on lui a parlé de
seconde
les effets secondaires de l'inrap si
robin de l'hydroxyde chloroquine dont ce
virus
on ne les connaît pas encore on sait par
exemple que dans le chikungunya la
chloroquine aggrave l'état des malades
dans le sida la chloroquine marche très
bien en éprouvette
mais chez les malades elle augmente la
quantité de virus qui est produit par le
malade
donc il faut faire attention ce n'est
pas parce que cette politique
et efficace dans le paludisme ou dans
les rhumatismes inflammatoires qu'elle
va forcément être efficace sinon j'ai
lancé une question pour vous oui m colas
week sommet mais je vous écoute avec le
respect que je dois à l'homme de science
moi je ne suis qu'un patient qui n'est
pas un patient de l'être croyez moi
parce que quand je vois le cafouillage
je maquille est un bon mais la polémique
autour de l'est donc si chloroquine elle
a été construit de toutes pièces
à un moment donné on ne sait pas
pourquoi on a pris la décision en
janvier 2020 d'interdire sa prescription
avant ça ne posait pas problème et vous
semblez dire si je suis je me méprends
vous me corrigerez bien sûr vous semblez
dire qu' il ne faudrait pas prescrire ce
médicament parce qu'on ne sait pas quels
seraient les effets retour sur le co
vide 19
mais jusqu'à présent elle a été
prescrite
on n'a pas eu d'effets retour que je
sache
alors pourquoi cette espèce de 2,2 de
crainte que beaucoup de médecins n'ont
pas eu pour le médiator par exemple par
exemple pour moi c'est un crâne presque
on veut pas on veut pas une deuxième
affaire médiator n'ont pas donné mais
moi j'ai une question à vous poser il ya
quand même de nombreux pays dans le
monde
pardonnez moi oui il ya quand même de
nombreux pays dans le monde qui
utilisent cette chloroquine et en france
ça sans me poser de multitude de
problèmes avec des débats sans fin
comment vous l'expliquez vous
effectivement laurent alexandre le
médecin vous savez c'est très simple
d'abord on est dans une ambiance qui est
très passionnel raul n'est pas à une
personnalité totalement simple donc ça
un petit peu pollué le débat quand il
expliqua pujadas et quelques jours que
pujadas ne peut pas comprendre ce qu'il
dit et qui lui dit pour nous départager
pour savoir si mon médicament efficace
ou port va faire un sondage voyez on est
plus dans la politique que dans dans la
science
finalement la bonne idée mais non c'est
pas une molécule à cause de la
personnalité de doctorat non non mais il
a beaucoup politisé beaucoup
personnaliser le sujet on peut pas dire
qu'il n'a pas été reconnue par l'état
puisque macron est descendu le voir à
marseille ce que ma crown affair et
qu'aucun autre chercheur donc au
contraire raul a été câliner par le
pouvoir et il ne faut pas oublier que le
responsable de la communication de raul
tu yanis roussel est très proche dans
marche donc on ne peut pas dire que le
pouvoir ma chronique n'a pas juste dix
mots en quoi ce que vous direz vous
parce qu'il faut bien comme ce qu'il
faut bien comprendre c'est que les
médecins ont beaucoup de mal
individuellement à retrouver les effets
positifs et les effets négatifs des
molécules
on a un exemple très très cruel en
médecine qui est l'exemple des anti
arythmique dans l'infarctus du myocarde
100% des cardiologues dans le monde dans
les années 80 pensait que les anti
arythmique était bon pour les malades
qui faisait un infarctus qui on a fait
un essai clinique versus placebo en
partageant les malades en tirant au sort
les malades entre ceux qui avaient le
médicament et le placebo
et puis on s'est rendu compte que les
malades qui prenait le médicament mouret
2,7 fois plus que les malades qui
avaient le placebo ça nous est très
difficile à nos médecins de juger de
l'efficacité des effets secondaires d'un
médicament sur la base de nos sols
patients c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que
l'on fait des essais cliniques qui sont
longs laurent lessard dément toujours
pas terminée
j'espère que vous êtes sur la liste du
rassemblement national la patronne de
votre mouvement s'est exprimé
aujourd'hui olivier vers on s'est
précipité pour interdire le traitement à
base d'hydroquinone au rocking tout cela
sur la base d'une étude frauduleuse
dénoncé désormais par de nombreux
scientifiques
est ce que le ministre de la santé ou
celui des lobbys est ce que vous
partagez la suspicion de la patronne du
rassemblement national parce que c'est
vrai que c'est beaucoup ressorti cette
affaire de conflit d'intérêts
lobby est ce que vous êtes aussi dans
cette suspicion c'est l'abattage
d'autant plus que j'ai fini tribune
il ya une dizaine de jours où je compare
et je l'assimilé l'industrie
pharmaceutique aux marchands de canons
ils ont ils dit nouri n'ont qu'une loi
c'est celle du fric et il est vrai que
que l'hydroxyde chloroquine coup de
quat'sous et j'ai très peur que l'on
veut il éliminer ce médicament au profit
d'un médicament qui sera peut-être le
même mais qui coûtera beaucoup plus cher
on sait que le gouvernement pardonnez
moi mais c'est important que le
gouvernement pousse le cynisme à vouloir
privilégier un médicament qui ferait
perdre de temps qui serait plus cher ou
profonds en défaveur d'un médicament
efficace vont donc être financière non
c'est la question est bien de pause mais
l'appui le patron de 0,7
j'ai oublié son nom excusez moi je ne
suis pas scientifique a lui même reconnu
que le poids des lobbys pharmaceutiques
était telle qu'ils ne pouvaient plus
avoir de communication scientifique sur
parce qu'il y avait un tel ou tel lobby
une telle manipulation dans les travaux
qu'ils n'avaient plus de certitudes il
l'a dit lui même c'est pas moi qui le
dit c'est lui à partir de l'orb
parfaitement imaginer que des gens de
bonne foi se font manipuler mais si
souvent manipulées sont pas à leur place
un mot tout à l'heure sur ce que disait
mon excellent contradicteurs il m'a pas
échappé que il l'a quand même adressé
une pique à la personnalité du docteur
out
je pense que ce médecin hors norme qui a
découvert je crois 12 médicaments quand
même sauf erreur de ma part dérange
le conformisme des autres voilà d'un
seul coup il a atteint une notoriété
bon on sait ce que c'est que les beaux
dessins d ordre dans tout l'est dans
tous les domaines et je pense que
véritablement il y a à la fois un combat
contre le médicament pour des motifs qui
peuvent être très honnête c'est certain
et très malhonnête chez d'autres mais
que la personnalité écrasante de cet
homme qui n'est pas dans le moule qui
n'est pas dans l'académisme dérange
aussi qu'il fait des jaloux il fait des
jaloux narcissique y voit là aussi c'est
le monde de la médecine et comme le
monstre du barreau et humblement des
médias ont une personnalité un peu
énorme
elle dérange crée des jalousies pourquoi
avoir évoqué docteur tout à l'heure le
fait que la personne qui s'occupe de la
communication de raout appartient à la
république en marge
en quoi ces scientifiques comme
observations en quoi laurent alexandre
la tra référence alors je n'ai pas dit
que c'était scientifique c'était juste
pour dire que quand on dit que macro ne
l'aiment pas macron adore raul t il
s'est même déplacé à marseille a reçu de
réponse au problème des lobbys alors
d'abord préciser que moi à titre
personnel je jure sur l'honneur de
n'avoir aucun conflit d'intérêts ni avec
les fabricants de la chloroquine ni avec
les les fabricants d'éventuels
concurrents de la chloroquine je n'ai
aucun conflit d'intérêt je le jure sur
l'honneur mais aujourd'hui il n'ya pas
de lobby contre la toux rauque in parce
qu'aucun autre médicament ne marche
c'est bien notre dame la chloroquine ne
marche pas et les autres antiviraux
hélas ne marche pas le remdh et et vire
de gilles ead ne marche pas et personne
ne l'utilisent
il n'y a aujourd'hui aucun antiviral
hélas ce qui marche on a espéré que le
remdh et y virent qui étaient des bleus
qui a été développé pour les sièges
vraiment magique et notamment la fièvre
ebola est la sienne marc burg pouvait
marcher
et il ne marche pas donc aujourd'hui il
n'y a aucun le biais à la manoeuvre
parce que les malades qu'on ne met pas
souple eurokin on n'aimait pas se joue
notre molécule à la place on les met
sous rien on les réanime on leur fait un
traitement symptomatique mais on leur
donne pas de médicaments puisqu'il n'ya
aujourd'hui mais aussi mon cas ça me
prend de son efficacité
on sait maintenant que la réanimation
qui a tué beaucoup
s'ils ont beaucoup de mal il ya plein
d'études d'autoriser ou non non c'est la
réanimation qui sont des malades
ne versez pas c'est comme s'il est fier
en tant que thérapie tu les tortues les
docteurs je veux pas jouer les les
médications je serais mal mal placé mais
il ya eu des études là dessus ça a été
dit ça a été dit qu'est ce qui a été dit
que de réanimer les balades qui allait
très mal les tuer que la non venue parce
que je n'ai pas dit ça alors vous allez
voir j'ai dit que de passer
immédiatement à la phase de réanimation
sans passer au préalable par un
traitement ad dropsy coquine et aux
antibiotiques mais la latte
franchement non là franchement je vous
assure qu' aucun médecin ne passe sont
malades en réanimation s'il n'y a pas
besoin de le mettre en réanimation
nous admirons les mesures uniquement
uniquement les malades y aller par des
tags à son prétendant
mais quel traitement si demain si devant
un malade atteint du 2e demain ou si mes
enfants le proco vide et main je prends
du paracétamol aujourd'hui la
chloroquine débauche de sons des mots
masquer son médicament n'est stationné
juste dire oui mais ils brigueront terre
on se rend pas compte à quel point la
situation est difficile et complexe dans
ses incertitudes
et franchement olivier derand a fait un
boulot super moment le 2 de l'accuser
d'être dans la main des lobbys ça fait
beaucoup roulent à pascal
merci à vous deux je perds collard à
l'aube sur 100 avec sans avoir des bons
coups